das ist praktiker mit vielen spannenden
fragen und vor allen dingen mit der
warum sich das universum denn schneller
aus den konnte nach dem urknall als mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit geht ja eigentlich
nicht geht aber doch das jetzt in fracks
ig und mit noch vielen anderen themen
die erste frage kommt von patrick wie
kann sich das universum beim urknall in
weniger als einer sekunde auf mehrere
tausend lichtjahre ausdehnen wenn es
laut einstein nicht möglich ist sich
schneller zu bewegen als licht mich
beschäftigt diese frage schon seit einer
sehr langen zeit und ich würde mich über
eine antwort von ihnen freuen beim
nächsten mal bitte dutzend ja also
erstmal vor dem urknall existiert weder
zeit noch raum und für eine sehr kurze
zeit nach dem urknall und zwar zehn
punkt - 36 sekunden das ist ein
bruchteil einer sekunde dehnte sich das
universum schneller aus als das licht
das widerspricht der relativitätstheorie
nicht denn es gibt eine ganz kleine
geschichte die es ermöglicht dass sich
der raum dass das universum schneller
ausgedient hat nämlich der raum selbst
hat sich ausgedehnt und licht bewegt
sich im raum mit lichtgeschwindigkeit
und kann sich nicht schnell bewegen der
raum selber kann sich aber schneller als
das licht aus den also mit einer höheren
geschwindigkeit und alle materie die
sich innerhalb dieses raums bewegt sie
würde sich von außen betrachtet zu
diesem zeitpunkt eben über licht schnell
bewegen und das tut sie aber nur relativ
innerhalb des raumes bewegt sich die
materie langsamer als licht und auch
heute noch bewegen sich galaxien am
anderen ende des universums relativ zu
uns schneller als das licht und das
liegt daran dass das universum sich
weiterhin aussehend und wir uns in
unterschiedlichen richtungen bewegen
text as tisch möchte wissen welche
auswirkungen hätte es wenn eine seite
der erde permanent einseitig von der
sonne beschienen werden würde
für die beleuchtete und nicht
beleuchtete seite ja das wäre glaube ich
eine
katastrophe es würde mich bedeuten eine
sehr hohe uv strahlung auf der einen
seite hohe temperaturen kälte auf der
anderen seite schnee eis keine
sonneneinstrahlung mehr also keine
pflanzen
es gebe auch kein leben mehr auf der
anderen seite und leben wäre für
menschen nur noch unter der erde auf
einem sehr schmalen streifen rund um den
globus oder mit schutzanzügen möglich
oder was immer noch vorstellen kann die
werden oben an den polen und würden
quasi immer hin und her fahren sich
bewegen um mal in der sonne zu sein und
mal nicht oder oder eben auch an also an
der linie wo leben dann ist dem die
zwischen der dunklen und der hellen
seite ist immer mehr gibt das könnte ich
mir noch vorstellen um dann quasi diesen
effekt zu erzählen den wir heute durch
die erddrehung haben aber das wäre eine
katastrophe wir haben ja das glück das
gibt es im anderen fahrzeug das sich im
universum alles dreht und von daher so
ein fall nicht auftreten kann
kleine welt fragte was glaubst du wird
die nächste revolutionäre erfindung der
menschheit sein also ich hab keine
ahnung also ich glaub entdeckung wird es
eine menge wahnsinn gegeben hatten wir
ja im letzten gibt's zum science fiction
video hollo meter also eventuell der
beweis dass wir nur projektionen sind
das heißt es ist wäre unser universum
wer wie die matrix das wäre eine sehr
spannende entdeckung aber keine angst
das bedeutet trotzdem dass wir
existieren vielleicht nicht hier so wie
wir uns sehen aber wir existieren sonst
würden wir das ja alles gar nicht so
empfinden wie es ist das eine tolle
entdeckung
ich glaube in der forschung was medizin
angeht wenn man eine menge entdecken ich
hoffe auf die kernfusion vielleicht
sogar die kalte das heißt bei niedrigen
temperaturen
das wäre eine revolution für die für die
energieversorgung teleportation wird ja
immer wieder bieten da wenn man sich ja
immer mehr hinkriegen
schauen wir mal also es wird sicher eine
menge geben aber wie soll man das vorher
sagen wir haben
letzten klicks um science-fiction
bisschen erzählt was es alles für
fortschritte 2015 geben wird also die
wird es mit sicherheit geben ja und
florian erfragt wie sieht die
bevölkerung lautet die er in 50 jahren
aus welcher religion wird die
vorherrschaft haben
was ist der altersdurchschnitt wie wird
es mit den geburtenraten ausschauen
ja also altersdurchschnitt da würde ich
sagen da kann ich was zu sagen wer wird
mit sicherheit steigen da bin ich fest
von überzeugt weil die medizin immer
weitere fortschritte macht gerade eine
aktuelle meldung heraus gefunden worden
warum roland wahle 200 jahre alt werden
ohne krebs zu bekommen bei uns ist das
ja auch ein tieferer todes grund zu
sterben weil eben krebs durch die
ständigen teil zellteilung und durch
fehlern dabei fehler dabei entstehen
kann
aber da gibt es halt immer einen
weiteren fortschritt geburtenraten wird
natürlich in der zivilisierten welt wird
die oder in der westlichen welt sind die
ganze welt ist der zivilisierten der
westlichen welt wird sie wahrscheinlich
weiter stagnieren sie wird weltweit
weiter stagnieren aber wir stehen
natürlich wirklich weiterhin vor dem
problem der überbevölkerung und wir
müssen damit zurechtkommen und vor allen
dingen unsere verbrauch an ressourcen
dringend reduzieren und ich hoffe dass
wir nicht wir verbrauchen ja mehrere
erden in anführungszeichen jahr auch
mehr rohstoffe als die erde und zur
verfügung stellt das ist nicht toll
ja und welche religion wird die
vorherrschaft haben also ich glaube
nicht an die vorherrschaft von regionen
ich glaube da an ein zyklus mal dass das
eine mehr in mode mal ist dass andere
mehr in mode
es gibt nicht die religion es gibt halt
den gott an den ganz ganz viele
religionen glauben und da wird es glaube
ich immer wieder den einen oder anderen
wechsel geben
wenn man heute für den islam und vor
allen dingen die die radikalen
islamisten sieht sowas gab es ja auch
schon mal früher als die christen
südamerika eroberte das war auch nicht
immer friedlich also solche tendenzen
gibt es immer wieder also das ist ja
generell was solche ideologien angeht
mal ist die eine mehr im fokus oder hat
hat sich stärker durchgesetzt mal die
andere es gibt halt nicht wir denken ja
oft es entwickelt sich alles vorwärts
und es gibt einen fortschritt auch
gesellschaftlich und politisch aber wenn
ich das so sehe ist dass immer wieder
ein vor und zurück und ist setzt sich
nie das beste was ist auch das beste
durch ja wenn euch dieses fraxinea
gefallen hat dann dürfte euch vor allem
das leaks letzte klick zum science
fiction gefallen denn da geht es um die
fortschritte des 2015 gibt an tollen
entwicklungen in der technik physik und
so weiter und so fort
die 2015 quasi unausweichlich sind
aktuelle news wie immer im block und in
der app dafür hier klicken und alle
links gibt's wie kindern in der video
beschreibung und was meint ihr
mich würde interessieren was glaubt ihr
was die nächste große erfindung ist was
wird der nächste große fortschritt sein
was wird sich da in der wissenschaft tun
schreibt in die kommentare und ansonsten
bis dann bleibt kann